bonjour mesdames messieurs ici je lis de
relève bienvenue aux ex dans un tout
autre décor vous le voyez regarder la
salle où on essaie d'un centre des
congrès à québec on est actuellement
dans le huit clos
ici tous les gens qui sont ils des et du
bien aussi de représentants de
différents groupes qui sont présents
tous ces gens là ont déjà eu accès à
tout le matériel du budget ça doit être
dévoilée par la suite à ces heures là
vous me regarder en différé ce n'est pas
en reste capsules que j'enregistre avec
vous avec les extérieurs avec mathieu
may violents qui sont avec moi bonjour
alors vous avez eu l'occasion de potasse
est justement le seul budget leur écoute
et les documents qu'on avait été épais
comme un bottin téléphonique
on ne fait plus rapidement possible je
joue savoir vos grandes lignes votre
regard qu'est-ce qui vous marque qu'est
ce que vous retenir du budget mais
dessus les attentes étaient élevées pour
le budget jolie vous le savez donc au
niveau de la santé par exemple ya des
bonnes nouvelles il y en a eu aussi des
moins bonnes dans les bonnes on pourrait
dire qu'un investissement quand même
important au niveau de la dpj et des
jeunes qui sont en difficulté on sait
que ça le fait beaucoup jaser au fil des
dernières semaines et les services
sociaux ont réussi à émerger du dossier
santé vous rappellerez c'est un dossier
qui englobe souvent cette partie
importante donc des soins de santé qu'on
donne à notre population et des services
alors là dessus ça c'est le point
positif au niveau négatif par contre
beaucoup les travailleurs qui sont dans
le milieu de la santé restent sur leur
appétit
on retrouve dans le budget encore
l'offre patronale initial du
gouvernement le bo les intervenants on
trouvera effectivement que c'est une
façon de valoriser leur profession dans
différentes maisons d'hébergement sur le
terrain et on a parlé aussi à plusieurs
intervenants
mais pourquoi beaucoup de fonctions
donné pour la formation donc pour lutter
contre la pénurie de main d'oeuvre dans
différents secteurs va falloir aussi se
pencher sur la question
wells avait de gros défis les pénuries
de main d'oeuvre mais reebok est ce qui
vous frappe
en fait c'est l'ambition mais l'ambition
qui est pas ok pas toujours positive
parce que quand on regarde par exemple
les perspectives de croissance
économique du budget on est à point 5 %
de plus que l'an dernier donc là l'an
dernier on disait en 2020 2021
on aura une croissance économique de 1.5
est finalement là on a une perspective
de 2 et quand on sait avec tout ce qui
se passe à travers le monde
mais là on se dit
le gouvernement aurait pu lever un peu
le pied mais en contrepartie on va dire
qu'on va probablement qu'on met des
mesures en place pour stimuler
l'économie
un nouveau crédit d'impôt pour
l'innovation qui va aider les
entreprises mais reste encore lent je
pense que ça va être le fil conducteur
pénurie de main d'oeuvre
beaucoup de déception ici parce qu'on a
six ou huit loup il ya beaucoup
d'organisations son action va présenter
et le mot vraiment c'était on a besoin
de monde on a des enjeux de main
d'oeuvre
comment on va faire pour réaliser par
exemple le plan québécois des
infrastructures
c'est comme un peu le fil conducteur
donc aider bonne nouvelle d'un côté
beaucoup d'ambition mais par contre
certains à un peu probablement ça fait
un petit problème pour réaliser tout ça
n'est pas dangereux comme les syndicats
et parents oui le patronat parce que
c'est ça on voit on rajoute des
milliards dans des chantiers dont ça
vous demande énormément de travailleurs
en fait il faut pour quelques courses
avant son chantier ça prend des gens la
grande question si on n'a pas la réponse
aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'on a suffisamment la main
d'oeuvre pour se vouer yolande qu'est ce
qu'il faut c'est sûr que sur la question
de main d'oeuvre je suis je partage
l'avis des collègues je suis parti quand
pour l'instant déçu je pense que d'une
certaine façon ça décrit un peu les
réactions de la salle
c'est pas vrai que les gens sont en
général déçu du budget c'est parce que
je retiens mais je n'ai pas senti comme
un enthousiasme non plus les gens sont
comme un peu comment vous dire en
attente ça gigote sur leur appétit c'est
à dire mais expliquez nous ce que ça
veut dire par exemple pour lutter contre
les changements climatiques
le gouvernement a mis la table pour sap
effectivement à 6,7 milliards sur six
ans c'est comme on dit bettman et
beaucoup d'argent mais dans les faits
est ce que on comment vont vantis alors
faudra voir ce que fait dans la
stratégie du gouvernement je sais pas
est-ce que c'est des ministres qui vont
dans les prochains jours les prochaines
semaines venir d'écrire et ventilés
commencé soulevons être vont être
déclinés dans la population
c'est un peu ce qu'on sent
en ce moment en tout cas c'est comme ça
que je vous l'avais reçu c'est ça parce
que les beaux environnements il est
écrit vraiment un gros step dans ce
budget là on essaie vraiment de marquer
l'imaginaire on essaie de convaincre ici
le public écoute et on l'a pris au
sérieux cet enjeu là on est en train de
le faire ce virage vert mathieu ça
faisait partie des choses que vous
alliez surveillez vous aussi on parle
beaucoup d'électrification ce que
j'avais ce qu est ce qu est ce qu on
peut transmettre changer un mot pour
l'autre est ce qu'on peut dire on fait
un virage électrique ou est-ce qu'on
fait un virage environnemental avec ce
budget ne pas écouter c'est sa yo yo des
bons points l'électrification des
transports est un élément majeur qui
ressort donc du discours de monsieur
legault on retrouve son pragmatisme dans
des projets qui sont concrets on a aussi
beaucoup de projets à venir
au niveau des transports collectifs donc
c'est ce projet qui ont été émis sur la
table donc sur certains aspects et
quelque chose de bien sur d'autres c'est
beaucoup plus abstrait on n'a pas
nécessairement toujours les détails du
nombre d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre que telles mesures pour réduire
on a aussi beaucoup d'inquiétudes sur la
façon avec laquelle le gouvernement va
donner de l'argent aux industries pour
pouvoir compenser leurs émissions de
carbone
est ce que les industries devraient pas
payer une plus grande part alors là tu
savais ta surveille aussi dans les
prochaines semaines le ministre quand
même dit monsieur gérard écouter on est
on est quand même dans une bonne
situation même lorsque on quand on
regarde l'avenir on voit des nuages
plutôt lourd plutôt gris mairie
effectivement cela obligeait les gays
sur puce mon budget avec beaucoup
d'argent
ceci dit les défis sont importants je
sais que des gens qui ont peu plus qu'on
parle du covan au virus
mais ça fait partie de l'équation ça
fait partie des risques de
ralentissement économique au fouet puis
là dessus mais évidemment on le savait
on l'avait appris hier
y a pas de mesure particulière et non
seulement il n'y a pas de mesure
particulière mais l'espèce de petits
coussins qu'on s'était mis l'an dernier
200 millions qui étaient là sur les
simples les cinq années budgétaires aux
disparus alors c'est 1,5 million qui est
pas assez je ne sais où
et là on a beau dire que le fonds de
stabilisation va contribuer le fonds de
stabilisation c'est un peu virtuel alors
c'est pas comme si on avait mis je sais
pas moi 500 millions de côté en disant
savez quoi
on sait qu'il va se passer des choses on
va tenter d'investir de manière ciblée
quand on saura ce qui fait en sorte
qu'on va probablement se retrouver si
jamais les choses devaient finalement
décliné mais peut-être avec un mini
budget parce qu'on serait on a en a eu
et on sait pas parler là dessus j'ai eu
la même réaction
j'ai l'impression qu'on comprend l'on
savait que le budget est prévu pour
aujourd'hui et le contexte de la
dernière semaine a comme changer la
donne et le gouvernement a compris la
décision qu'elle n'ait pas changé le
budget en conséquence
mais avec tout ce qu'on voit que ce soit
coronavirus sur corner 19 ou bon le
virus en question
le baril du pétrole aussi l'économie
mondiale j'ai l'impression que le
gouvernement va devoir se ressaisir de
toute façon c'est comme si oui
aujourd'hui c'est le budget de la
connaît alors que les choses ont changé
et c'est ce qui fait qu'en puis on sent
dans la réaction des gens ici dans la
salle aussi qu'on est comme ok mais est
ce qu'on a fait les ajustements
nécessaires en fonction de ce qu'il y
est d'arriver à suivre à suivre
lorsqu'on comprend ce que je décode dont
je vous écoute parler c'est que vous
reste un peu sur votre appétit pour les
détails durant ont volé mon temps
maintenant on voit pas encore le commet
là dedans et il reste les réactions si
ce qui vous suit et finalement mesdames
messieurs avec toute notre programmation
spéciale vous allez voir les groupes de
pression vous allez voir les partis
d'opposition vous allez voir aussi le
public vous même est ce que vous allez
être satisfait aussi de ça ce qui nous
donne l'occasion de revenir de mai mais
dans nos studios pour faire la suite de
ce budget là qu'on aura davantage le
grand grand portrait de toutes ces
réactions donc on continue internalise
c'est une grosse journée
merci beaucoup les ex merci mesdames
messieurs là demain